revisiting 2023 preseason prediction so
for Cardinals I'm not going to lie to
you 4 and 13 Tyler gets a couple wins at
the end of the year I think the
Buccaneers are going to win the division
Jordan love will be the best quarterback
to ever walk through the Packers uh
franchise Packers are going to the
playoffs all the hype about Rogers the
guy can have no offensive blocking at
all he could snap his ribs and the Jets
go back to being the same old
[Music]
Jets Falcons have got the potential
they've got the players the only thing
that I'm still nervous about Arthur
Smith think the Steelers are going to
win their division this year uh
no definitely no one comp beete Phillies
out the way Giants are out the way
Cowboys all the way 11 and six no Browns